Good morning.
We are now on page 582.
We're going to start
test number four.
So let's start with the first
problem, problem number one.
When Miss Jung arrived at the
grocery store, there were five
packages of hot dog rolls
left on the shelf.
One package contained 12 rolls,
and each of the other
packages contained 8 rolls.
So there's five packages, one
contained 12 rolls, and then
the other four contained
8 rolls, right?
Because there was 5 total.
If Miss Jung bought all five
packages, how many hot dog
rolls did she purchase
at the store?
So it's 12 rolls from that
one, plus 4 times 8.
Well that's 32.
So 2 plus 2 is 4, and then 44.
So she bought 44 rolls,
and that's choice C.
The hardest part there is
just the multiplication.
Number two, A, B, and
C are points on a
line in that order.
OK, let's draw that.
So there's my line.
OK, so A, B, and C are points
on a line: A, B, and C.
If A, B equals 30, and B,
C is 20 more than A,
B-- so B, C is what?
It's 20 more than this,
so it's 50, right--
what does A, C equal?
So what does this equal?
Well it's just 30 plus
50, it's 80.
And that is choice D.
Next question.
And I will change colors.
Problem number three.
If x plus 3 is equal
to a, then what
does 2x plus 6 equal?
So the really fast way of doing
this is you just say
well, you know what?
2x plus 6, that's the
same thing as 2
times x plus 3, right?
And what's 2 times x plus 3?
Well x plus 3 is a, so this is
going to equal 2 times a.
And that's choice C.
And that's the fast
way to do it.
I mean, you could've done x is
equal to a minus 3, and then
substituted this in here, and
said 2 times a minus 3 plus 6.
You get 2a minus 6 plus 6, and
you would have gotten 2a.
This would have taken you
like 15 extra precious
seconds on the SAT.
So if you saw this, immediately,
this would have
been a better way to do it.
But this would have also
been a correct way.
The next question looks like--
well the next couple of
questions I'll have to do
some drawing for it.
OK, so they plot a bunch
of points out.
I'm trying to figure out how
I can draw the minimum.
I don't have to draw
the whole thing.
So that's the y-axis, x-axis.
Let's see, scores on tests.
I'm just going to draw the
points that look like-- so I
don't have to draw
the whole thing.
So you have points A, you
have point B here.
You have point C.
And then they have
point D here.
And then they have an E, which
it looks like it's the same
level as the B, point E.
And so we get where we are.
So this line right here,
that's a 60.
And then they draw another
line right here.
And then this point
right here is 80.
That's 80, then this line down
here looks like roughly--
let's see, it's 40.
And where the C is, looks like
there's a line here.
Then the C is, there's a
60, then a line, and
there is a 80 there.
And in the book it says
the x-axis is the
score on test one.
And then the y-axis is test two,
the score on test two.
I know you can't read what I
wrote, but you can look at it
in your book.
Score on test two, so
these are the test
scores of five students.
So problem number four asks us,
for which student was the
change in scores, from test one
to test two, the greatest?
So which student either did
really bad on test one and
then improved to test two, or
did really good on test one,
and then kind of degraded?
Well let's see.
Let's get the chart.
So student B scored a 40
on test-- let's do
it actually in order.
So what was the change for A?
These aren't the choices, these
are just-- actually the
choices are the same
as the letters.
So A got a 40 on test
one, right?
Got a 40 on test one-- just
read it here-- and got
a 70 on test two.
So the change is 30.
B got a 40 on test one,
and a 60 on test two.
So the change is 20.
C got a 60 and a
70, that's 10.
D got an 80 and an 80, so
it's no difference.
And then E got an 80 and
a 60, or minus 20.
But the change is
still just 20.
We could write minus 20.
But the biggest change is
choice A: got a 40,
and then got a 70.
So really improved on
that second test.
And number five.
What was the average-- the
arithmetic mean-- of the
scores of the five students
on test two?
So the y-axis is test two.
So let's just write them out.
Student A got a 70.
Student B got a 60.
Student C got a 70.
Student D got an 80.
Student E got a 60.
So 60, I don't know if
you can read that.
And then there are five
points, right?
So let's see, we could
just pretend
like this is a student.
That's a 60.
So let's see.
What's 7 plus 7?
Is 14, plus 6 is 20, plus
8 is 28, plus 6 is 34.
So it's 340 divided by 5.
And that equals what?
5 goes into 360, 68.
That's the average, or
the arithmetic mean.
And that's choice C.
Problem number six.
OK, they do a bunch of stuff.
I guess I should draw it too.
That's the line they drew.
And let's see, it's
going like that.
Let's see, so it goes
from minus 2 to 2.
So it's minus 2, minus 1, 0,
1, 2, and extra space.
So you're going to draw a bunch
of points, so I'll do it
in a different color.
So this is t.
And they have u,
v, w, all here.
And they put an x
here, then y, z.
So that's y and there's z.
They ask us, on the number line
above, t, u, v, w, x, y,
and z are coordinates of
the indicated points.
Which of the following is
closest to the absolute value
of u plus v?
So this is just an approximation
problem.
So you just have to kind of
look at this and guess
what u and v are.
So it looks like u is
about 3/4 the way
to negative 1, right?
So I'm just going to assume
that u is equal-- or
approximately equal, I can
do a squiggly equal-- u
approximately equals negative
3/4, right?
Because it's almost
at negative 1.
And then v looks halfway between
0 and negative 1, so
that looks about negative
1/2, right?
I don't know if that's
exact: negative 1/2.
So what's the absolute value
of minus 3/4 minus 1/2?
Well that's equal to
the absolute value.
You get a common denominator of
minus 3 minus 2/4, right?
That equals the absolute
value of minus 5/4.
The absolute value of minus
5/4 is equal to 5/4.
And if we look at the choices,
5/4, that's a little bit more
than 1, right?
That's equal to 1 and 1/4.
1 and 1/4?
This is 1, so a little
bit more than 1.
It looks like choice y
is our best answer.
So that is choice number D.
See you in the next video.